hoy en pasado el mediodía se reactivó el
conflicto armado en la frontera entre
armenia y azerbaiyán el ministerio de
defensa de armenios manifestó que
azerbayán está utilizando artillería
pesada vehículos blindados y armamentos
de diferentes calibres la parte armenia
también afirmó que hay soldados muertos
y heridos aunque no en números
confirmados sobre la cantidad también se
han registrado 12 soldados armenios
cautivos por parte de las tropas a
series y dos posiciones de combate
perdidas hace instantes el ministro de
defensa de armenia sur mbabi qian quien
fue nombrado ayer en este cargo tuvo un
encuentro telefónico con su par ruso a
quien le planteó la situación que se
está viviendo en la frontera y enfatizó
en la invasión de las fuerzas armadas
sobre territorio armenio por su parte el
ministro ruso manifestó que va a ser lo
posible para
a estas hostilidades mientras tanto la
situación continúa tensa en la frontera
entre armenia y azerbayán
específicamente en la región de sonic y
con el transcurso de las horas crece la
preocupación de la sociedad